oh hey cool now I can stop calling it
the new one that's coming out in 2017
maybe I guess god I hope they don't ruin
it again
hey everyone [ __ ] fine more
spider-man reviews god Progress nature
to man oh come on this game gives a
two-minute advertisement for Oscorp
before it gives a title screen that's
weird and off-putting I guess
nanomachines sudden speaking of
advertisements I thought be Knox had a
pretty good street going with this
series but then a new movie came out and
I feel like someone up the chain of
command pressured them to build hype for
it by putting this together it doesn't
follow the events of the movie and
actually takes place after it so it is
different from most tie-in games in that
sense they took a lot of concepts and
gameplay elements from throughout the
series and decided to build some from
the ground up or improve on earlier ones
while also shoving in new ideas this
game is the definition of a mixed bag
and assuming you're one of my
subscribers you've probably been dying
to hear me rip into it although I think
it actually has some merit here in there
like just for you let's start off by
talking about the story my biggest
problems are with the story
everything is so poorly thought-out and
comes off as being either really odd or
generally unfulfilled 90% time set in
the universe of the amazing spider-man
films Peter and Glenn take a tour of
Oscorp to investigate the shady
behind-the-scenes stuff going down there
both are shocked to find that for some
reason there's a bunch of half-animal
people just skulking around in cages
right where anyone can see why are they
working on dangerous projects like this
in the middle of a crowded city aren't
these the kind of experiments you should
be doing and like the desert or
something whatever having this game be
in a first-person view would have been
awesome but it's only for this scene
they couldn't get the rights to any of
the actors faces or voices from the film
so spider-man sounds like a ninja turtle
and has never seen without it
hey where are you going auntie pizza
with your adopted turtle sons
can I come I already miss Josh Keaton so
much
this new guy sam riegel just doesn't
sound right to me he always sounds way
too excited or he emotes like he's an
anime character I did everything I could
to save you you've gotta hold on for me
you gotta fight what so it's really over
the top and takes you out of the scene
but back to the story Peter starts
stumbling around talking with Alistair
Smythe and Gwen when suddenly his powers
make him a target for these cross
species and they riot for some reason a
plague that mutates people and the
animal monsters breaks out and as a
result Gwen is put into a quarantine
while spider-man goes off to find a cure
so immediately the whole plot is a
result of all of the characters being
idiots
Gwen sneaks Peter into the lab in broad
daylight
Peter doesn't get some distance to keep
the mutations at bay just sort of stands
there while the situation gets worse and
Smythe lets these two high school kids
go on a tour of something that is
without a doubt highly illegal and super
dangerous literally the worst thing that
could have happened happened you dumbass
this happens twice
spider-man's arrogance leads to another
prison riot it happens a lot I guess the
plot then focuses on everyone trying to
contain eradicate or cure this virus and
every character makes the situation turn
out as poorly as possible by being
incapable of basic logic the plot is
generally dumb but there are a lot of
little issues just under the surface
that I feel are worth talking about to
every creative decision is problematic
somehow right off the bat I'm noticing
something that I always wondered about
these movie license games what if the
developers had no idea what the next
movie was about and jumped the gun on
the story here Rhino is a well Rhino
that was injected with human DNA and
came more man life though in the next
movie Rhino appeared as a guy in a
pseudo Iron Man outfit both of these
ideas are terrible but some consistency
would be nice
Alistair Smythe despite being kind of an
obscure character is in the sequel but
here he looks pretty different from BJ
Ryan started the fire Novak this game
even seems to have a weird disconnect
from the movie preceding it - especially
with spider-man fighting enemies on such
an enormous scope like this robot the
movie gave the impression that
everything was more grounded in reality
and he wasn't supposed to be an Avengers
level badass he was even successfully
taken into police custody for being a
vigilante the only reason he got out of
that whole situation is because he knew
the right people and got to leave by
smooth-talking that depressed fireman
but now I can do anything
this game's idea of dealing with a
plague is so confusing that any
intelligent themes that could have been
used are made no by the silly extremes
the characters go - you expect me to
believe that Oscorp is capable of making
giant mecha robots to exterminate people
with the virus okay one this company
does genetic research why do they have
giant robots that'd give Godzilla
difficult afternoon - when something
that massive and destructive caused more
damage than it fixes Ono simit bulla got
into the streets of NYC better launch
the Reaper or martyr I guess Oscorp
having hilarious and stupid giant robots
isn't necessarily you in these games but
good lord they sure upgraded peter has a
base in Manhattan because he's
house-sitting for someone named Stan
I'll give you three guesses how that
subplot works out one of the other
problems with the writing is also
immediately apparent at the start of the
game I wish spider-man felt more like
spider-man patients can leave their
rooms it's your fault you gotta help me
I have to help you you tased me bro huh
no there's something so off about his
personality and 90% of his dialogue is
confusing in some regard
if I never see another air vent gotta
stay up high
use the ventilation ducts I do love me
some ventilation ducts why is this
opinion of ventilation shafts so
inconsistent and he keeps flirting with
Asian reporter Tricia Takanawa for some
reason you're that reporter on TV
Whitney Chang what are you doing I was
gonna ask you the same thing well good
to know you like to be on top and I
don't usually go this far on a first
date mmm you didn't try to kiss me did
you I wanted to but you were drooling so
yeah I don't give my number on the first
day wait I don't okay okay you
forgetting something oh I don't normally
give out my number to mask' to Landy's
if that's what you mean
wait why if you gave her your phone
number from earlier you wouldn't need to
ask for her as if she calls you you can
just add that number as a contact so f
bucket like Gwen is in the quarantine
zone praying for her life that you find
a cure for her genetic mutation and
you're making googly spider eyes of that
lady from the news channel what the hell
spider-man you [ __ ] at least make her
wear a skin-tight leather outfit and
beat you up on a rooftop like that other
girl and another running theme that
bothers me this game feels desperate to
be modern spider-man is constantly
making jokes about his social media and
referencing his cell phone hum going
just don't expect a friend request
anytime soon
and the loading screens show you random
internet comments regarding the
situation in the plot just the Internet
well clearly none of the developers had
ever been there before because they
think people still actually use the word
heck or people on the street without
their Sony brand phones to take a
snapchat of the guy who just stopped
them from getting mugged it's like a bad
recent Simpsons episode where they try
way too hard to remind you that they're
hip and cool with the modern age ah even
the game map is a phone hey did you guys
know Internet we knew Internet wait
Peter
take the oven on the table the what it's
the name of the Oscorp phone the Oz
phone that is Oz fold huh huh okay how
about this it sounds like the name of a
radio show hosted by Ozzy Osbourne I'm
sorry you're 15 you don't know who that
is
said the 17 year old I'm an [ __ ] as a
teenager and user of social media all
this does is ruin things for me I hate
seeing internet references and memes
shoved into mainstream media because it
always comes off as struggling for
relevance it's gonna be outdated in a
year no matter what I'm doing with my
life I should be studying flirting with
cheerleaders and playing wow the story
in writing just compounds on itself with
increasingly bad ideas and Goofy and
consistencies but there is hope for this
game gameplay in design wise it's pretty
different from usual standards and
there's a lot to talk about so the
majority of this review will probably be
gameplay concerns one of the first
things I noticed is that this game is
clearly trying to mimic Arkham in a few
ways the combat system is similar the
structure of narrative and locations is
similar there's even a mission where you
fight escaped mental patients I suppose
I like how it limits spider-man a little
for the basic fights he isn't doing
silly things like ripping chunks of
concrete out of the ground and swinging
them at people it's just really
acrobatic fighting with a hand of
martial-arts and parkour in there I
actually like it a lot it doesn't go too
over-the-top and end up feeling weird
and look they brought back that thing
from ultimate spider-man where if you
don't web up the crooks they'll just
keep getting back up
probably because Arkham did something
similar but whatever wait not whatever
you know what let's play a game called
Arkham did it press triangle to parry or
dodge attacks vault over riot shield guy
to hit him in the back
vent crawling no spider-man on the ps1
did that too so they get off on a
technicality for that one
silent takedowns challenge mode where
you can play as other characters and
compete for leaderboard scores
haha you get the idea
said stealth is very similar to the
shattered Dimensions way of doing things
but this time there's a button to
quickly retreat into the darkest corners
of the room if you get spotted which is
more useful than just using conveniently
placed gargoyles like Batman does the
challenges as other characters are
pretty cool because they actually made
unique missions and gameplay for rhino
and lizard they even had a DLC to
celebrate spider-man's fiftieth
anniversary by playing a Stanley in the
open world map oh yeah web-swinging is
completely redone in a way I think is
just great
the camera is closer up to feel more
like you are spider-man it's the
difference between controlling a car at
a distance or having the camera right
inside the windshield
it's even easier to go up and down
quickly though that's mainly because the
webs don't attach to anything it's just
shooting off into the sky oh well I
always just assume spider-man's webs
function similarly to light rays where
it will hit something eventually he just
shoots a web and it snags on some
far-off celestial body for all we know
he could be grappling onto the moon or a
random asteroid in space or even another
planet with intelligent life what a
fascinating creature this
physics-defying enigma known as
spider-man he can jump five stories in a
single bound that's absurd
he could do that he wouldn't even need
the webs wait do you mind if I sidetrack
for a second how high can spider-man
jump while doing some research it's
generally accepted that he can jump at
least 36 feet though using jumping
spider facts some can calculate
proportional height of about 150 feet
but then I remember one time in a
spider-man 2099 book where they say 50
feet if my knowledge about human anatomy
is true doesn't that mean
miles can jump even higher alright one
more for old times sake
there's this thing called web Rush mode
where you can slow down time and find a
place to perch or web zip over to I do
have to admit I did find myself swinging
around for fun more than I wanted to do
the story missions it's a blast to just
go swinging around for the hell of it
nothing we haven't seen before but
different enough that I like doing it
again especially after the last two
games took away the free roam and the
more you do it the cooler it looks the
web zips have so many animations and
works so well you could travel without
having to swing they basically invented
two different ways for spider-man to
travel around and both are pretty
awesome hey isn't this the place where
spider-man dumped the dead body of his
clone not the clone but another clone
the first one and something I think
would get overlooked is the fact that
they even fixed the wall crawling the
controls for that have always led to
some shenanigans because the analog
sticks switch directions when he comes
to a corner now they have a handy
reticle and you can move in the
direction you're facing it's nice that
they thought of something small like
that being that they could have just
ignored it like every other dev who's
worked on this character although it's
kind of sad when the Lego games do a
better job of recreating scenery from
the movie than this does I'm happy to
have free roam back but most missions
put you back onto a linear path I guess
the indoor sections were too hard to get
out of their system after the last two
games and while it does look ok at first
glance the open world also feels
surprisingly small despite being one of
the biggest cities in the world I can't
tell if it's because the buildings are
all shorter or if I'm moving too quickly
but some piece seems off somehow
it might be that spider-man is taking up
more of the screen and now feels less
like he's in the city and more like he's
superimposed over it it's a double-edged
sword with that new camera angle it has
pros and cons and I still can't decide
if it was a bad decision or not and you
can entertain yourself during boring
dialogue segments by splatting white goo
all over your friends while they talk I
feel like I'm having a hard time picking
apart the gameplay the swinging is
awesome and the fighting
feels fresh there's just something
really wrong and I can't put my finger
on it I just absolutely hate something
about this and I can't figure out what
um oh I got one
no what's better than having comic
characters in the game
taking pictures of random inanimate
objects they'd interacted with in order
to imply that they exist ooh there's a
park bench that mr- sat in do I get to
fight him no here's a bench see this
vulture was here isn't that spectacular
it's like watching agents of shield all
over again oh no
the photo taking missions are neaten all
but does it have to save every single
one of them onto my Playstations hard
drive who would ever have a use for that
it's just taking up space this game also
makes my ps3 sound like it's dry-heaving
to run this disc but all my other games
sound fine it's not like the graphics
are that intensive or anything
in fact the graphics aren't all that
Pleasant at all
spider-man looks less like a cartoon
character with massive eyes no mouth and
red and blue skin he just looks like a
guy in a costume the problem is that
he's about the only character model that
looks good especially for 2012 we don't
reach spider-man 3 standards but we
skirt the line a few times and that
isn't helped by the ugly color scheme
this game looks like a Michael Bay movie
but what the hell uh another fun thing
of note I'm glad I recorded this I
encountered a bug where Spiderman kept
auto walking into a corner in a hallway
I jumped away thinking I had figured it
out but it started back up again in a
later room at the level I found out he
was gonna do it every time he touched
the ground
so I had to complete ten minutes of this
level without ever standing on the floor
is that a Zeppelin
this isn't Gotham City what's that doing
here I'm a weapon
oh my god it's him Bruce Campbell's say
you can do fun side missions for Bruce
Campbell who plays a weirdo reporter
that wants to film you doing sick bball
moves it's like a dude perfect video
there's a nice return to a simpler time
here this one feels a lot more video
gaming if you know what I mean
you get unlockable costumes from taking
pictures of these Spyder logos
everywhere and you can collect comic
book covers like in the ps1 games except
this time you can actually read those
comics you'll end up picking them up as
often as the stupid spider tokens you
know spider-man never really struck me
as the type who would like comics or
even TV for that matter I feel like he
just has too much [ __ ] to do all day to
watch TV or read books why ulcer his
reference is always so dated I also like
using the unlockable costumes ah [ __ ]
not you again I switched into the suit
from the 2002 spider-man at the closet
in the game's hub area because I was
feeling nostalgic from my childhood
well I guess I can't change back now can
i [ __ ]
I'm stuck in this thing now which I'm
sure pisses off Sony a little but you
know hey it's their fault for putting it
in the game speaking of nostalgia one of
the boss fights is almost identical to
one from spider-man three though that
isn't exactly my definition of a fond
childhood memory and much like
spider-man 3 the bosses are all sort of
bland you either have dumb aerial
battles with robots that would give most
people motion sickness where you do
other fight son ceremoniously in a
parking lot how exciting
Rhino you fight him in a parking lot
lizard fight him in a parking lot
Captain America flight him in a parking
lot black cat will fight her in an
underground parking lot so she can use
stealth moves on you she's the only
character that wasn't rewritten to be a
drooling monster now she's a heartless
bank robber with no grace or subtlety
she doesn't even have powers she's just
got a gun and boatloads of sexual
attention which is odd because this
version of spider-man still isn't even
18 yet and this adult woman is crawling
all over him
bye Felicia I also can't believe they
were so tapped for bosses to fit this
story that they had to resort to using
as e-list villain like Berman yeah
anybody remember that guy the whole
third act of Cravens last hunt was about
him the only character I can think of
that's more obscure a slide the man who
uses nonstick cooking spray as a
superpower I wish I was joking about
that I went into this game wanting to
hate it but there are some awesome
things hidden behind the lackluster
story and dumbass representation of all
these classic characters and
inconsistent writing and attachment to a
subpar movie series boy
writing turns me off to everything
because I don't care what's going on
it's less about being a superhero and
more about dealing with a deadly
outbreak of some silly disease I just
want punch rhino stop flogging me down
with all this prototype knockoff crap it
gets too hard to ignore - they even take
my superpowers away for a while and I
have to walk around on the ground like a
chump in the midst of
all this doom and gloom which I guess is
something they haven't done before but
it could be done better maybe have
spider-man attempt to fight a super
villain to keep up appearances and fail
to learn some humility or use his wits
to win instead of his powers to succeed
anyway you know character building the
citywide plague concept is a strange
direction to take it and I feel like
that could have been done better to wait
it was New York having some kind of
epidemic was shown in web of shadows in
that game had the benefit of interacting
with the greater Marvel Universe to
express the severity of the situation
and the first half of that game was
essentially business as usual to help
show how the outbreak changed the nature
of spider-man's role in the city
throughout the story this game is just
spider-man vs. the world right from the
start everything that makes a great
spider-man story is absent
there's no well-written villains just
one-dimensional reboots of them that are
completely wrong there's no side
character from the comics either other
than Gwen it just feels so neutered for
content what stay back let's play Doctor
Wow those two guys in ski masks just
tried to sexually assault this lady in
broad daylight in an empty parking lot
in perfect view of the sidewalk in the
street Frank Castle did nothing wrong so
to sum it up this game has some flaws
that stick out but I would still say it
isn't exactly bad it was hard to keep it
even out for this review because this
game is right down the middle for me it
isn't shitty enough to hate but it isn't
good enough to love either
the gameplay is generally solid and
actually really fun if a little
uninspired so we'll give this game a
pass on a technical level but the story
stringing it together is annoying
whether you're a fan of spider-man or
not the writing and boss fights
constantly make you roll your eyes and
say really that's what they went with
the final scene is so abrupt why do the
end credits make me think I just watched
an independent film about 9/11 just slow
panning shots of New York and
melodramatic music 0 out of 10 not Call
of Duty here's the kicker this game has
its flaws for sure but it's still not
inoperable there is a lot of room for
improvement and at the time you'd think
they'd come back around for a sequel
that addresses all of the issues right
right nope